Inflation has impacted many areas of our lives such as gas, home, and grocery prices,...
...but it has also impacted the cost of dating.
Infla-dating is a new trend where couples go on less expensive dates...
...due to the rise in prices and everyday expenses.
From walks in the park to cheaper dinner ideas,..
...the cost of dating is now having to take a creative turn.
But luckily, we have Ted Jenkin here with us today to talk about infla-dating...
...and what this means for the dating scene right now.
And Ted, tell us what is infla-dating,...
...and are people actually overextending themselves financially on the dating scene?
Yeah, well, good to see you Holly.
Look, in this term infla-dating, which you're gonna hear more of,...
...it's really just a way to describe going on lower cost dates as you talked about,...
...while we still have rising and spiking prices in food and drink...
...and just going out overall.
We saw last week that inflation was still north of 7%.
But a lot of people that are in the dating scene realized...
...that dining out and entertainment is still at double digit growth.
What's interesting is that 22% of all millennials right now say,...
"...Dating is making me broke."
And 85% of all millennials right now are saying,...
"...You know what, it's okay to go on a lower cost date."
It's costing the average person more than $100 a night to go out...
...and it's costing the average dater more than $3000 across America...
...over the course of a year in their budget,...
...and in urban areas that can be double or triple.
So, it's expensive right now for dating with inflation being high.